hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast methods to account for
sequencing artifact in large
high-throughput RNA seek data presented
by Joseph Paulson PhD research fellow at
dana-farber cancer instance Institute I
am Kristen present a love lab Ruth and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is as
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button on the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Joseph Paulson I will now turn the
presentation over to him Thank You
Kristen hi everybody I'm happy to be
here today as Kristen said I'm going to
talk about a particular instance in our
approach for accounting for day
sequencing artifacts in large
high-throughput RNA seek data and so
right now currently I'm in the
Quackenbush lab at a Harvard School of
Public Health and Dana Farber and I came
to this lab to learn how to do
networking
which is very very becoming much more
common with these large high-throughput
sequencing data that's becoming
available and I stole a few slides from
him on how not to do network analysis
and once I explained how not to I'm
going to explain the the approach that
the pipeline that we developed to
normalize and do quality control of
large high-throughput RNA seek data so
that we could get good robust networks
out so many people often take often take
RNA seek data they might have two types
of phenotypes healthy disease or wild
type and knockout and they do a
statistical comparison and they subset
on the set of genes and they get
differentially expressed genes those
that happen to be associated with
phenotype one or those are associated
with phenotype two they take a protein
protein interaction Network and they
start coloring the nodes of that protein
protein interaction network and they
generate what's commonly what we refer
to as bio poetry so should one question
is should things that are differentially
expressed be connected why is that
necessary and is the PPI network even
relevant
another common approach that you don't
recommend is where you do the same
statistical analysis for example you
might use GC core edge R or T tests to
find the differentially expressed genes
and you also subsequently
using all the data estimate correlation
networks so then you'll inferred color
you'll color the nodes of those
correlation that works again and do your
bio poetry so one question is are things
that are correlated functionally
connected and our correlations the same
in different phenotypes
why are you aggregating all the data to
perform these correlations so the way
that we do may work in
we recommend is you do your specific
separately on the two different
phenotypes when you infer your networks
so you infer a phenotype specific
network and from each of those networks
you and you analyze the network topology
and structure you compare the network
topologies and you simultaneously can
compare the differential structure and
expression and this can give them more
phenotypic specific network and one that
you can make more sense of hopefully and
so in the lab we've been developing a
lot of different regulatory network
methods including one called panda and
we released recently on bioconductor a
package called panda our that allows you
to estimate the gene regulatory nodes
which are different from Co expression
Miller's I won't get into that today but
we had a number of various network
approaches and methods that we wanted to
analyze that we wanted to tackle a lot
of the open questions with RNA seek data
but we needed we needed so here's the
Panda Arthur that's a package but we
needed a big sandbox to actually play
around with our methods and test a lot
of our hypotheses biological hypotheses
and see how well our methods work on
large data so we found a big data set a
big sandbox called the genotype tissue
expression pilot analysis gtex
foreshorten and what it was was it was a
big sandbox in that it had over 450
genotype donors there were approximately
in the in there what's called he begat
that of nine thousand five hundred or so
samples so these are four hundred and
over four million fifty individuals that
we had about around 50 or so 54 tissue
sample
and their transcription from each of the
tissues was our sequence so we've been
working quite a bit to analyze this data
using our own techniques and a number of
the papers have been either there in
review or they just recently got
accepted and I'm going to touch on a few
of them today especially the processing
and normalization pipeline and you can
go to some of these tiny URLs to find
the bio archive the preprints for these
for these papers
this one is tinyurl.com slash gtex 0 1
so I'll write that real quick well and
Wellcome such key tech 0 1 and there
you'll find the bio archive and preprint
available to read in case there you have
any questions of the for this
presentation or you can email me of
course
so if we go ahead and we look at Keele G
naught expression omnibus on the
internet we can we can download quite a
few datasets of our nice ik data however
the majority of them here we have a
histogram where the y axis is the
frequency the number of samples we're
presenting the number of samples in each
data set from Gia and the majority of
data sets in geo have less than 50
samples ok now we have a data set this
gtex cohort that has nine thousand five
hundred or so samples and a lot of the
methods that have been developed for
analyzing transcriptomic data have been
developed with these sample sizes in
mind so it begs begs a number of
questions number of questions arose with
this beautiful large resource first off
what is the quality of this particular
data
and how do we go about looking at
quality help them where our different
tissues new to each other in healing
it's one of the biological questions
that we have what's an appropriate way
to filter RNA seek data and how do you
appropriately normalize the data that's
a very important question because you
put in two samples let's say you have
the same exact sample you put in sample
a so sequencer at time one or and then
we put it in again at time two you're
going to get to the kinetics hopefully
not too different but you want to create
a good you want to normalize that
absolute a simple a simple be
incompatible so our solution is yarn yet
another RNA seek package and it's like
pre-processing and normalization of the
jika it was developed for pre-processing
a normalization of gtex expression data
and other data sets and if you just want
to go and grab the normalized gtex data
you can just go to this URL right here
there are 35 lines or so animal pre
process and run all of the commands so
that you have great quality data to go
and ask your own biological questions
it's currently a bio connector package
that became recently available and you
just need to install the software and
then you'll be able to do everything
that we talked about so basically the
yarn method is a six step workflow just
like you do six minutes abs every day
and you'll get a six pack after a couple
of months right you follow the success
workflow and then you look in no time
whatsoever you'll have that a perfect
data ready for beautiful figures for
your manuscript analysis I apologize
with some of the images don't come out
very clearly but you can download the
PDF of this entire presentation and you
all look okay
so here we have the pre-processing or
normalization workflow that we just that
I'm going to describe and the first step
is getting the data sometimes that can
be quite a hassle I won't go into some
of the struggles we had with DB gap but
that is oftentimes an issue hopefully
none of you ever had that issue if you
like I said before if you go to this ten
URL comm pre-process G text you can go
and grab the data at least the publicly
available version so grab the data step
two you want to do some quality control
and filtering of samples you want to
filter samples that have poor annotation
quality for example they might there
might be little evils in a phenotype for
those different samples there is a paper
that recently came out in one at 1,000 a
new sample is it anyway yes
widespread miss annotation of sample and
transcriptomic studies and they
identified in geo that there were
apparently 46 percent of the datasets
had at least one miss Whelan and and
this was a text of the annotation for
sex weather example was from a male or
whether it was from a female and so
along the way we might see some code in
red and that those are just some it's
just some code that you can use from the
yarn package that will allow you to
generate figures like like this one like
what I'm presenting here what we what we
can do actually what we decided to do is
to take PCA its principal coordinates
analysis and take control a set of
control genes so it's a very simple
content where you take subset of genes
that you know will be descriptive of
phenotype for example we can take the
white chromosome genes and I don't I
don't remember which tissue this is but
you can subset to a particular tissue as
a mere video
and we subset it just to the control
genes y-chromosomal gene and we did a
PCA plot what we observed was that all
the females clusters on one side of the
PCA and all the males clustered on the
other time except for one particular
individual heat exile pen and you can do
this for all the different tissues and
you'll see that in the gtex cohort at
least is very clean in that they had
only one individual that was
consistently your sample so actually
when we put this paper upon by our Casa
we actually received information that
using the PCA method did a good job as
in terms of quality control they were we
were told by the birds that actually GE
exile pen is known to us as a patient
levity sex reassignment surgery so this
one simple approach image it's very
necessary because a Mis annotation
mislabeling is widespread in a lot of
transcriptomic studies oftentimes we
find as high as 10% of the samples for
example TCGA might be most annotated and
so this is really just the first step
when doing high to put one using
hypothetic doing some analysis is to do
the quality control Silk'n hi the next
question is about merging tissues so
there might be multiple conditions that
are separately labeled but if you could
combine them you might get increased
power you might have initially very
small sample sizes for different tissues
or conditions but if you were to
aggregate them all you could have a
reasonably sized study so one particular
question we can use PCA yet again on
perhaps the most variable gene those
that are hopefully delineating
one condition from another once issue
from another and to see that for example
I apologize the colors aren't really
coming up let's hear what we have let's
look at the middle figure on the top
panel let me use my arrow this one and
then this one so if we look at the first
one we see that there is on the left
part of the plot we have cells so these
are fiberglass so they were designated
in one of the labels as skin even though
they're just transformed by the left and
then on the right hand side we had skin
that was sun-exposed Seabrook suprapubic
and sun-exposed lower leg and Sun
unexposed and when you look at the most
variable genes and we do a PCA you can
see a separation of the cell lines of
the cell line from the tissue of origin
the progenitor addition but when you
look at just the skin samples as in the
Sun exposed some unexposed young see any
separation between the two groups so
perhaps one way to do this would be to
analyze all of the the skins the cells
separately and then to analyze the Sun
exposed some unexposed together you can
combine those two conditions with two
groups as one in other instances where
we look at blood vessels we saw that
there were three really distinct groups
of the aorta
coronary and to do so just the things to
consider if you perhaps them to merge
samples or conditions for increased
power our exploration actually led to a
result that was surprising for us that
Pelham's in the tissue of origin it
quite a bit
here the lower lower right plot we see
that whole blood and LCL or blood LCL
samples they perfectly said they were
perfect on the first acts principal
component separated from the skin
samples the skin and the fiber blasts
and I'm the second component the cell
lines separated out from the tissue of
origin so I'll talk briefly about that
at the data without a visible so that's
great once we've decided to what tissues
to actually merge we have to consider
filtering genes because there are
sometimes maybe measurements that come
through in the sequencer but you don't
want to filter too - too much because
there's some tissue specificity when we
began analyzing the setup someone had
suggested that we filter anything that
present at some level some minimum
threshold being half of the data
fortunately when you're dealing with
many different conditions like this
that's going to remove many different
tissue specific genes for example and
there are number of examples that we see
in box plots here these are just some
that I randomly chose to highlight and
and so it's important to consider these
these thoughts for example what happens
when you look at just the most variable
genes but let's say the top 10 or top 15
in a blood vessel of samples of just
looking at the samples of blood vessel
samples what we see is if you do too
harsh you know filtering you lose out
that tissue specificity here we have a
dendrogram and the coloring at the very
top represents the three tissues we see
the tibial
mostly aggregates together but then the
I order and the corollary to teacher
samples aren't really separated up but
when you preserve the tissue specificity
exam we see three different groups in
our cluster and these are just of the
top ten most label a system is variable
G so things are just things to consider
when you're doing a analysis so once we
once we've done about there are our last
question really is about normalization
okay there are a number of different
approaches in normalization and and I'll
get to that in a second but just to
rehash so we started off with close to
nine thousand six hundred samples we had
55 thousand genes 54 tissues and through
the process we either
threw out a number of samples to get
quality control throughout genes that
were very lowly expressed the details of
that are in the paper not in the
preprint and beyond a software manual
and to this point now we have nine
thousand four hundred thirty five
samples 30,000 genes and thirty-eight
tissues so we've been able to aggregate
number of these tissues for increased
power for example for eqtl analysis so a
málaga want to normalization a very
important part where we have simple one
and we have several two and we want to
make the two samples comparable as I was
saying they're roughly two normalization
techniques one is where you have a
scaling one is a steering approach for
example I don't recommend this but you
divide by the library size or by this
sequencing depth how many reads are
there so that you can get a proportion
of see how many
what proportion a gene is in a given
sample that is one type of approach and
there are many different approaches used
by DBC signature one is called RLE CMM
and other library size those are called
scale to normalization approaches other
approaches are global distributions
where there are different types of
assumptions and you make a you're not
dividing by a constant you're not
dividing by the median counter or some
other value instead you're transforming
the distribution so let's look at over
here in the top left corner of this plot
let's look at this plot just to get a
quick understanding of normalization
here what I'm displaying are these are
three different data sets each column
represents a different data set but just
imagine for a second that this is what
we have here are each one is the
distribution of counts or here it's
actually love to PM values but let's
just imagine it's the chat log count
it's going to be each line representing
individual sample and if the x-axis are
the values so for example you might have
a gene that represented that has 10
reads assigned to it another gene that
has 200 reads so 200 would be here you
know to 1 read would be here and how
many genes that are represented at 10
there are quite a few or the majority of
the distribution is it now what we see
here with all of these samples is that
they follow a similar ish structure but
that there's a lot of variability
between the different samples let's take
a look at
this example where there's less
variability there's some but it's much
more tight and if we look at the colors
we see that the conditions also tend to
be different we see that there are a
number of samples that are orange and
when you have separately a number of
samples that are agreed and that
business is still difference in how the
distribution looks between those
conditions whereas in this first part we
had three conditions again we had
asthmatic smoke or nonsmoker samples and
we could not really distinguish between
the samples between the distributions
based off of the phenotype or the
condition of interest and then here on
the far right we we have even more
samples and we see that the green that
our brain and the red happens to be
liver and they have very distinct
patterns okay so this is just what it
looks like without normalization there
used to be a technique that was that
become more popular with a statistical
method called boom for differential
expression analysis that is quite
powerful especially when you have a
large sample sizes so once you have more
than 100 samples you probably want to
move away from BC - oh I'm a jar and
work with them and the type of a
normalization approach recommended there
is quantile normalization and what that
does is it forces all of the
distributions onto one similar reference
distribution that is taking from the
average of the quantile so need to find
this reference of the average of the
quantize and then you force each of the
samples to follow that same frequency of
that single distribution so one issue
with this this method is great but the
assumption is that the variability
in the distributions of all the very
simples comes about solely due to
technical variation okay and that you
can control that variation by forcing
them all on for the same distribution
what happens here though what we
observed was that there were two
conditions
it had very distinct distribution and
that was a biological artisan not a
technical out of that at least we
believe so so this Rasul approach that
just actually got accepted yesterday
Hicks at all and live statistics called
a smooth quantile normalization that we
will do essentially will do quantile
normalization when there is no
distinction it will appear on things and
it will do it separately or it will do
scaling it will do it basically simply
when there is a difference between the
two conditions and so here we see
bringing in liver for example plotting
off to the two defining their own
distributions and that's okay so just to
go back to the gtex data what we
observed here is that there are
distinctions between there's a lot of
variability first off we have a lot of
samples there's going to be a lot of
variability between the different
samples not only that what we're
observing is each other narrow we see
that the scale at zero is increasing you
see the density the spike method there's
a spike method Europe they're a lot more
tissue specific gene
so as we're adding more and more tissues
we get a lot more zeros because a lot
more Jews that are tissue specific and
the distributions are fairly distant
from each other they don't look too much
so initially but once you add more and
more
becomes fairly clear and using quantum
normalization in this instance would not
be appropriate and so when analyzing the
gtex data one should probably do a
compound are smooth quantum memorization
which you see here is a close up
apologies for the mess of it here we
have we're plotting the district with
density density here's the expression of
the distribution for all the testis
samples in the gtex color and all the
artery typical samples and you see the
ones we Zulu see these distinctions the
distinct a transcriptome distributional
profile for each of the two tissues we
see a very simple and end also the
variation what I'm not showing you guys
is that scaling the scaling
normalization approaches like what easy
or ajar use are nothing to be enough to
control for that variability between
samples and so by using a quantile a
smooth quantile analyzation we're
actually retaining the biological
profile of these two tissues while also
controlling the technological
variability there i we can ignore this
these top two plots instead let's look
at the bottom two what happens also with
quantized normalization here are two
examples where here on the Left we have
no no no noise ation and we see TB x20
it's a important gene for that known to
be in the heart or expressed highly in
the heart and we observe that in the raw
data actually of GK these - these are
box plots of this particular gene of the
expression
and we'll see that it's highly expressed
bloom height heart right atrial and
heart right ventricle samples and it's
not so highly expressed to him most of
the other samples however once you do
quantile normalization this can actually
introduce errors because we're defining
this reference as an amalgam of all
these different tissues the expression
for T V X xx sat down to an almost
non-existent in in our heart samples but
for some reason in other samples it shot
up and became very highly expressed and
that's just an artifact of the
ionization technique and so some people
need to be aware that these are issues
to consider so at the last point on the
normalization is that you can think of
you can look at the IMS see the root
mean squared error of each of the
individual samples to the full reference
so what we have here on the y-axis we
have the root and Twitter so the
difference between the sample samples
transcriptome and the reference log
transformed and everything the log
difference we have the written Twitter
and we have for each of the different
tissues in each and so we have for each
of the different issues we of the Box
Club and what happens when we define a
full reference just like what is done in
quantile normalization we often see that
their high their high value in squares
and their the lower IMS seems the better
now when we define a tissue specific
reference and and for each tissue and we
know do quantum memorization on that
tissue for example we get much lower
our MSU and that's one example of why
one of the advantages of doing something
like long time
smooth quantile memorization then the
newer approach so what we just discussed
where the word five steps are a number
of steps to actually go about getting
the data performing a high quality
filtering okay
merging tissues so that you could get
increased power for whatever analysis
that you might want to do culturally
genes to get rid of noisy measurements
of while the teen tissue specificity or
condition specificity whatever phenotype
of interest that you're looking at and
then there and then of course
normalization to make simple a and that
will be comparable to then do your
differential expression analysis or to
developed it we are ready to regulatory
networks unless that the final step the
most fun step is really to do an
analysis and a number of different
number of different analyses that we
have done so far have included tell line
transformation looking at sexual
dimorphism looking at the difference in
tissue specific regulatory networks
between all the different issues during
each ETL tissue specific networks
understanding how system trails eqtl
make up these networks and whether the
tissue specific effects or global and
then the number of other questions that
we've tried to address and they're all
available on bio archives preprints if
you're interested I'll just briefly talk
about one of them I'm talking about the
transcriptional landscape of cell lines
and the tissues of origin so if you
remember back to the PCA plot that I
made over here so in the bottom right
hand corner
we have on the y-axis pc1 and on the
x-axis pt100 on the y-axis pc2 and what
we observed was that salaries and
progenitor and the progenitor tissues
are quite distant from each other
and I think most biologists and people
I'll just know this but to what extent I
don't think that was well understood and
so we did it we have a computational
approach for actually understanding what
pathways and what genes are in a high
throughput manner we finally were able
to understand a little bit better these
questions so what we did was this gtex
cohort is great it's a big sandbox we
took we did a number of comparisons we
big differential expression analysis
comparing whole blood and LPL right the
difference between LC LC l cell lines
and the whole blood and tissue of origin
and of course you know these whole blood
and skin the combinations of different
cell types but this health helps us
understand just the difference between
us then we took the analysis in the skin
and fiber life samples and similarly
whole blood and skin and LCL in fiber
life and in total there were 89 cared
samples so from the same individual we
had 89 we have 89 samples that had all
four there were parents is 244 paired
samples between skin and fiber left and
there were 127 paired samples between
whole blood and LCL so we did two two
types of analyses the first one was
differential expression analysis where
we generated a list differentially
expressed genes you move that technique
I mentioned earlier room which is
available in luma
and we then performed pathways we looked
for pathways that were differentially
expressed using gene set enrichment
analysis we did gene regulates and then
we analyzed separately the network
topology of the gene regulatory networks
using that panda package that I was
linking to understand key transcription
factor regulators looking at the
transcription factor degrees and to
understand which pathways were
differentially targeted looking at the
gene degree so a lot of the results
actually make sense but as I was saying
this is a nice computational approach to
really investigate what we know
beforehand so some of the pathways that
are differentially expressed between
cell lines and new tissues of origin a
lot of them made sense
it's either way well you can look at a
number of them but for example cell
cycle is more expressive Ares is a
pathway that for the differential
expression that are more associated with
they're more enriched in felon example
so the Poisson pathways that were
enriched for at least two groups in
terms of a comparison we had immune
signaling that were enriched for the
blood and LCL cell line that makes sense
cell cycle and DNA repair pairs just
being enriched in the cell lines
extracellular matrix pathways that were
in which the skin and fiberglass and if
our ourselves junctions also enriched in
the extreme by the best pathways
and then what we did after we did the
gene setting like an analysis and the
pathway comparisons we looked at the
transcription factors and the gene genes
to understand how what what the
differences were between them so like I
said we took the LCL samples and without
the network separately we took all the
whole blood samples and built a network
also so that's and then we compared the
topology between the LCL and whole blood
in a separate analysis we then give
fibroblasts
gene regulatory Network and we did skin
gene regulatory networks and we compared
the topology of those two members to
understand so what we could do is we
took the gene we took the gene in degree
difference so understanding what
transcription factors were associated
with which GE and we could we took all
the genes associated with cell cycle and
various pathways and to sure that there
were lower gene in other words there was
lower gene in degrees for a number of
these pathways for a number of these
genes associated with itself cycle
compared to other non cell cycle
pathway genes so with that I really want
to thank a lot of the people that did
these analysis with me tomorrow
Lopes Ramos doing cell line
transformation if you go and check out
sexual dimorphism Charlie Chan septum
Hicks smooth quantum inhalation Maude
and John platter EQ tale tissues uh
specific networks IV Mary Kay Kimmi
doing tissue specific regulatory
networks and with that I also have to
thank my boss John Quackenbush at the in
Farber Cancer Institute and Harvard
School protocol and thanks
Thank You dr. Paulson for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for it looks
like we have a couple of questions to
start with our first question is where
is the manual for the yarn software okay
so the right oh okay okay great thank
you very much yeah so the manual and I
might as well answer the second question
also at the same time being reported
bioconductor a it's bioconductor is a
repository for very statistical software
packages I'm looking for like yarn and
to smooth the smooth quantile
normalization package or panda are what
you can do is you can actually go to
bioconductor that org
and you search for yarn what you'll see
then you'll go to the website and you
will see a home page once you get to the
yarn bioconductor package you'll see
you'll see this screen ok and to install
the package you just have to run these
two commands in your AR session after
after you do that right below this
there's a something called a vignette
and you can either type in vignette
clothes projects quotes quotes yarn and
they'll open up the yarn manual but
that's only after you've installed and
loaded the yarn package in CRS session
so to install it don't forget you have
to go to this
go to this URL and find it URL for going
to a directly to yarn is let me type
this in I'm conductor
Thank You Jess sure so that is the that
will take you directly to the website
way okay well if there are no more
questions that I would like to once
again thank dr. Thompson for his
presentation I would also like to thank
rabbaroos for making today's educational
webcast possible and before we go I want
to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through August the 2017 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye
you